thank you
okay when I come back so after having
evolving particles on static networks
now we will have a talk about evolving
networks by Shankar uh from UNC Chapel
Hill
thank you
um yes and also you know having uh
attended lots of really good talks at
some point there has to be a regression
to the mean sort of average so my goal
here I'm going to take a hit for the
team so this will be back to sort of a
bad talk
um so uh so I'm just going to sort of uh
tell you a brief uh so I'll start with a
brief motivation and structure and um so
maybe the first five minutes of the talk
are important after that you can
completely zone out but the plan is the
main parts of the talk there are three
different settings where somehow what
one might expect in dynamically evolving
networks and this is something that Lutz
also gave a beautiful talk
so what you might think happens doesn't
quite happen so the first topic is sort
of seed detection and dynamic networks
the second is sort of change Point
detection and the third is sort of
co-evolving networks at a very baby
level
so I should mention to all of this is a
joint work with cyan Banerjee and then
parts of this I work with Ian Carmichael
and Zoe Huang
okay so again so first part you know
right now I'm going to quickly tell you
the three the motivations of three
problem areas this is the only important
bit rest our specific contributions you
might not care about sort of the main
thing I want the case I would like to
make is that lots of interesting
problems and even like baby questions in
this area are completely open
okay so the first question is sort of
seed detection in evolving networks you
know trying to understand uh when let's
say you have an infection spreading on a
graph or something and you don't quite
know where the infection started from
maybe you know who has been infected and
you want to understand who is patient
zero sort of more precisely suppose you
have some sort of dynamic Network
started from a single node or some seed
graph and You observe the network when
it is of a super large size let's say
million nodes
and now uh so you know who's infected
maybe even connections between people uh
on the network so who might transmission
paths but there's no temporal
information you do not know who is
patient one patient two and so on you
only know the network topology and now
you're given a fixed budget a budget of
size 13 sort of so main point here is
sort of independent of the size of the
network and your goal is to Output 30
vertices in the graph such that with
high probability your seed is in the
output set so can you do this
um again you know the main math
non-trivial math fact not found by me is
in many cases uh you can do this for
families of graphs you can come up with
a budget independent of the size of the
network where you can find patient zero
the second area sort of change Point
detection you know change point in time
series is a very classical uh question
in in statistics
um so for example life expectancy uh if
you have sort of Time series
um when are there sudden changes abrupt
change something shocks the system and
then there's a there's an Abrupt change
in in the in in in the time series so
for example life expectancy you know
there are various sudden shocks to the
system in the US where there's sort of a
drastic drop all the way in during
so it's still to be seen how much the
pandemic will cause a drop in the life
expectancy in the US but uh so the basic
question is in the context of networks
suppose you have some sort of temporal
network data and uh it could be the
adjacency Matrix of a graph it could be
time series observations at each node of
the graph and now suppose at some point
in time the network experience is a
shock
then the question is based on let's say
observations of the network can you
detect this change point and in
particular to make math statements about
this you need to know how does this
shock change structural properties of
the network
so this is the sort of second area that
I'd like to tell you about and sort of
the the third area is sort of network
co-evolution I didn't realize you know
there are all these Superstars here uh
Frank P um Siva Adrian thinking about
these problems Kavita mentioned these
but uh ours is a much simpler question
but the the motivation is similar so
most real world Network models they
support some particular purpose so for
example diffusion of information uh
that's the purpose of say Twitter
but in many cases sort of the network
influences individuals so if I'm on
Twitter I would get information from
Twitter but then I would also influence
the network you know I I maybe I follow
other individuals in the network and so
now this opens up other chains of
information propagating on the network
and to a large extent lots of uh at
least theoretical work is uh they keep
these two things separate there's either
Dynamics uh on a fixed Network you know
you have random walks or epidemics on a
fixed Network or the network itself
changes but there isn't necessarily A
Dynamics that's influencing this
and so uh my main goal here is uh for a
very super simple math model I would
like to uh there were some conjectured
phase Transitions and I would like to
tell you about these phase conditions
and so what is the the universal uh
story behind all the models I'll tell
you in today's talk so all the network
models will have the following structure
where you have some sort of uh Network
at Time Zero at each stage an individual
enters the network and tries to form
connections to pre-existing vertices
using some probabilistic Dynamics so
that is the the unifying theme in all
three stories
okay so sort of uh that's it so now you
can sort of completely zone out here so
first question C detection and evolving
networks so again you know this is the
the basic question come up with an
algorithm which doesn't depend on the
size of the network which allows you to
track down the source of the infection
so the simplest model of such an
evolving network is the so-called
preferential attachment model where you
start with some attachment function f
and so now you start with a single
single vertex and at each stage a new
vertex enters the system and connects to
one pre-existing vertex using something
and let's say uh to keep things simple
we say that a person with large degree
they're more likely to get connected and
how popular you are that depends on this
function of your degree okay so this
function could be sort of uh constant
and that means your degree has no role
to play people just come into the system
and randomly connect or you you come
into the system if it's an increase in
function of degree the more uh
individual friends you have currently
the more people want to connect to you
so that's sort of preferential
attachment time behave type Behavior
and we're going to call talent to be the
network of size n
okay so uh should I wanted to use the
iPad here but so uh random recursive
tree that basically means at each stage
the new vertex comes into the system it
doesn't care it just connects to someone
randomly in in the network okay so the
degrees don't play any role sort of you
can simulate this I think around 3000 uh
vertices and so somewhere way in the
middle of the tree suppose I just plot
the the network uh without any temporal
information the network started over
here so the red vertices I think this is
vertex one this is vertex two and this
is what X3 sort of shows up slightly
weirdly but uh this is where the network
started
okay and so again what is the question
if I just gave you this tree
can you identify uh and I told you I'm
going to give you a fixed budget you are
allowed to Output 20 vertices can you
tell me where the tree started with
reasonable probability
sort of a much simpler model for these
sorts of questions is sort of
preferential attachment where if this is
the structure of the tree at any time
then the popularity of this vertex is 2
this vertex has popularity one actually
sorry uh this has popularity two this
vertex has popularity three one and one
and so then you connect with probability
proportional to the degree so people
with more friends get connected with
higher probability
and uh so here you know if you just look
at vertices so again the network started
over here this looks kind of red here
and uh intuitively if you know uh
maximal the if you know degree
information uh sort of trying to go near
the vertex to the maximal degree will
give you a good idea of where this
network actually started from
okay so sort of this uh this area
started with like fundamental work of a
whole bunch of
people's joke and low and so on and
there's sort of a math definition of
what a root finding algorithm is and
essentially what it's saying is suppose
you have some temporarily evolving
Network and now at some stage n n equals
a million nodes you remove the the
labels so labels represent when vertices
enter the system you remove the labels
you just give uh you're just allowed
access to sort of the topology of the
network no temporal information then the
question is is there an algorithm so
namely a mapping that takes your network
and outputs a subset of the network
and what you'd like is the following so
someone has given you an error tolerance
Epsilon then what you need to do is you
need to come up with an algorithm which
has some budget K this K would depend on
Epsilon
such that your the algorithm that you
that you've come up with so again the
algorithm takes your network outputs a
subset of the network uh it only uses
topological information
um it only outputs K vertices but what
you would like to happen is for your
probability model the probability that
your vertex One belongs to the output
Set uh the probability of that is
greater than or equal to 1 minus Epsilon
okay so K should be independent of the
size of the network it doesn't matter
whether you have a million nodes a
billion nodes trillion nodes Etc you
should just be able to do this so that's
the basic question
and in particular how does this depend
on Epsilon okay so uh would for example
um yeah
the dependence in epsilon means you mean
that as n gets larger you want Epsilon
to go to one in that sense no no okay
what do you mean so so good so Epsilon
is given to you and what you would like
is you you know if Epsilon is smaller
naturally you need to Output a bigger
set right and so the question is is an
order one over Epsilon enough is your
budget one or Epsilon is that enough is
one or Epsilon Square it or do you need
like one or so first off it's not even
clear that you can do this without say
outputting log in vertices or something
you know something that depends on end
sort of the remarkable finding of these
people is uh for a whole class of models
you can do this
but now the the next question is how
does this depend on Epsilon on your prop
for your probability model
okay so sort of that's the first
question and uh the most natural passage
of us these C detection algorithms is so
you don't have temporal information so
you look at your network you compute
some sort of centrality measure of every
vertex in your network so for example
you can look at the degree or you could
look at something called Jordan
centrality which I'll come to but your
favorite notion of centrality and then
if someone tells you you have a budget
of K then you output the top top could
be the smallest or largest depending on
on how your centrality works the top key
vertices
okay and uh so once again so you say
that these sorts of algorithms have
error tolerance Epsilon for a given
choice of K if the probability that your
seed belongs to what you want
um in your outputted set this is greater
than or equal to 1 minus Epsilon
okay and so uh sorry uh answering sort
of siva's question so the main question
in many of these uh probability models
is how does this depend on Epsilon is it
one or Epsilon is it one or Epsilon to
the 100 one over Epsilon to the one one
thousand Etc how does it depend on your
error tolerance how much budget do you
need
and there's sort of a related question
which someone said is related
topological data analysis which have no
idea about which is a notion of
persistence
and so here the question is the
following so once again if you have a
sequence of let's say growing networks
so the networks are all sort of coupled
then you can say you can ask so is the
degree maximal degree is that persistent
so namely is there some finite time
finite random time let's say within time
1000 after which the identity of the
maximum degree does not change so after
time 1000 Whoever has the maximum degree
they will forever be have the maximum
degree if it probably there of course
depends on this 1000 but if something
like this happens for a a centrality
measure then a potentially that suggests
that you can use that centrality measure
to uh to Define seed seed finding
algorithms because basically what this
is saying is within some finite time the
let's say degree fixes itself the
identity of the maximum degree fixes
itself so you go to the maximum degree
and your root will be somewhere near
that maximum degree
okay so all of these are sort of
Hallmarks of long-range dependents sort
of the origin if you have an evolving
Network model somehow what happens way
back in time has a major impact on how
the network itself evolves and this is
what also looks sort of alluded to in
his talk
so the uh the the finding of uh bubeck
Deborah and duboshi is the following so
from for a bunch of uh Network models
the following centrality measure
actually works so max degree centrality
doesn't work it's sort of easy to check
for say the random recursive tree where
things are randomly connecting so what
they found is the following so then just
a note this centrality measure is only
defined for trees so it's a big open
problem if you have Network information
how do you do these sorts of questions
but suppose you have trees then what you
can do is okay you're trying to check is
did the network start from this vertex
so one thing that you could do is okay
this vertex has three children if you
did start from here it has three
children so you look at the sub trees
hanging off each of these three children
there's one over here so the size of
this subtree is one the size of this sub
tree is uh three and the size of this
purple sub tree is nine
and so the centrality of a particular
vertex is the size of the largest
subtree of a child of V
and so the basic idea is suppose I say
did the network start here so I look at
this vertex it's a leaf the size of the
the the centrality score of this vertex
is the rest of the graph which is n
minus 1. so the you don't maybe expect
that the network started here and so the
larger the score is the less likely you
are convinced that maybe the network
started from there so somehow the more
within the middle of the network you are
the smaller this score will be
and so this was sort of first analyzed
by bobek Devoe and lugoshi and so what
they did was they sort of thought about
this for two classes of models the
preferential attachment model and the
random recursive tree
and it turns out there because of
connections to polyone schemes you can
do lots of exact calculations and in a
beautiful sea a beautiful paper they
found you know how many for uh for given
Epsilon uh how what should be the budget
of your algorithm so that if you use
this centroid uh centrality score you're
able to find the route with high
probability how does that depend on
Epsilon
and so sort of what we we carefully
thought about was you know suppose you
have some general attachment uh model so
your the way that your network evolves
depends on some function if you have
sort of proper if you know something
about this function then if uh we
derived um sufficient and necessary
budget requirements using the centroid
centrality score so if you're going to
use that particular centrality then it
turns out that if you have so much
amount of budget given an Epsilon if you
have so much amount of budget forget
this uh this much amount of budget than
with high probability so probability
greater than or equal to 1 minus Epsilon
irrespective of how large the network is
the uh the output that you give will
capture the the origin with high
probability and again if you're going to
use that same uh centroid centrality
score you you need
um sort of at least I think the error
should go the other way oh okay sorry so
this is sufficiency bumps so uh
depending upon the properties or
assumptions that you make on your
function you can derive sufficiency
bounds you need at least so much
um sorry if you do if you have so much
then it's enough and sort of also uh
necessary bounds so you need at least
sort of same order of magnitude
so I assume your f is always monotone it
can't make it more likely to connect to
less degree Fighters the very question
no it does not have to be monotone there
are technical conditions on the F but it
does not have to be monotone you know
this is basically saying you know it's
bounded in a linear fashion in some
there are some more technical conditions
but it does not have to be monotone oh
interesting okay so it doesn't have to
be monotone this is just saying it's
bounded but uh
and but this is a you know very good
question we uh the conditions are
reasonably Technical and it isn't clear
what kinds of things break the theorem
is it is it just existential or you have
an algorithm practice no no I'm sorry
yeah so maybe I went through too quickly
so take this specific centrality measure
and this yes so this works for any of
these cases
so they're sort of uh sufficient uh
sufficiency bounds necessary bounds for
this particular Central I mean whether
this is the best Etc that's not known
I'm sorry this means this means the
lower bound that you have right I mean
it's quite general you know it needs
yeah it's quite General it's not always
clear how tight they are so you can try
to see what kinds of results you get for
specific choices
yeah
what if your graph is sort of globally
tree-like so maybe there's a sort of a
few small Cycles once you contract them
it becomes a tree you would expect that
then and let's say these local
communities are bounded in size so you
could sort of say there's some finite
constant right and that can contract
vertices of that many into groups such
as the whole thing becomes a tree very
good question right I mean it would be
interesting to see something like this
works there as well I mean and I guess
there's a work of the Berkeley crowd
like Michael Mahoney who kind of says
that many Real World Systems look like
that like locally tree like sorry
globally tree-like but locally community
just to be sure so the lower bound is
also for Jordan centrality yes yes these
are going to work with budget bounded so
it doesn't not apply with other
algorithm very good question yes no so
another so um if one goes back to the
worker bobek divorce they for specific
models of networks they're able to
analyze like the maximum likelihood
estimator and because of that uh you
know these
so for this model and this model
preference attachment and uniform
attachment uh they basically show that
any
um algorithm has to have the same order
for those specific uh models any
algorithm should have this this complex
right you need at least this much so
exactly so the question is uh you know
are there other algorithms that can do
better if you if you're allowed to use
any sort of any estimation procedure so
because of the particular structure of
these two things they're able to find
these lower bounds but trying to do this
for General functions completely open
and super cool problem main issue being
figuring out what the likelihood is ETC
is intractable in those settings
okay very good question okay so sort of
uh before switching to the to the next
topic sort of the main uh there's a
natural uh question which is
you know um
all of this is all of this requires
Global Information about the whole
network so one question is you know
suppose you only have for every vertex
you have local information you know
maybe it's degree and maybe a bit more
information uh under what conditions can
uh you use local information like say
maximal degree I'm just going to go to
the vertex maximum degree hopefully
where my infection or network started is
somewhere there so under what conditions
does this happen and so I'm not going to
go through this too much but the basic
punch line is there are conditions on
the the attachment function f for your
network model which tells you when the
maximal degree works and when it doesn't
and in particular
so if you have attachment functions of
the form FK which is K to the alpha so
degree proportional to some power if
Alpha is between half and one then it
turns out maximal degree is enough you
go to the maximum degree and your source
of your network is somewhere near the
maximum degree whereas if Alpha is
between
um 0 and less than a half
then sort of you need you cannot do this
so the location of the maximal degree is
very far from where the infection
actually started
okay so this is sort of the first part
where somehow because of long-range
dependence there's a lot of information
in the initial part of the network which
allows you to do various reconstruction
problems
so the second sort of question is sort
of change Point detection and so I'm
just going to skip this and so the main
um so once again the the motivation is
suppose someone came up with a network
model initially that for some specific
reason you know some evolving Network
model say preferential attachment with
some probably proportional to some
function of the degree
okay so for example this uh famous Casa
models is barbasi Albert model where
this function is assumed to be some
linear function of the of the degree and
the reason they came up with it was it
sort of gives a a nice simple story for
why maybe Real World Systems have heavy
tail degree exponents so if you have
this sort of attachment function f of k
equals K plus Alpha then it turns out
that if you look at the degree
distribution of the graph then the uh as
n becomes large it stabilizes to sort of
a deterministic probability Mass
function which has this sort of property
so the exponent of the limiting degree
distribution as an exponent which is
Alpha plus three
okay so this is sort of known but now we
can ask the following question suppose a
network used one particular attachment
function f of K which is K plus Alpha up
to time n gamma and then from time n
gamma onwards up to M so somewhere in
the middle there is a shock to the
system you know a politician came into
Twitter and started using Twitter in a
completely crazy Manner and so the whole
Twitter uh the way that Twitter uh sort
of evolved completely changed there's a
shock to the system
so suppose this happened then can you if
you just let's say let's say you're
allowed to view the entire network
Evolution process can you find out where
this happens what is this camera
and so the the first question we thought
about was let uh so
so this is the change Point model let's
say uh up to time n Gamma One use one
function f and let's say that function
is K plus Alpha and then after time n
gamma all the way up to n which uh
rescaling to one let's say you use a
different function uh K plus beta
so if you use the yellow function for
the entire segment then the degree
exponent if there's no change the degree
exponent will be Alpha plus three if you
use this different function G for the
entire thing no change Point your degree
exponent will be beta Plus 3. so what
should happen if there is a change Point
somewhere okay in particular just to get
some idea you know let's say this gamma
is super duper close to zero
um so that the natural guess is you know
this stuff should determine what happens
to the network
and the basic punch line is irrespective
of how small gamma is you know gamma
could be point zero one or point zero
zero zero zero
super small irrespective of how small
gamma is the initializer function the so
the function f basically controls uh
lots of macroscopic properties in
particular the degree exponent of the
graph so going back to this picture it
doesn't matter what gamma is
um again gamma could be point zero zero
zero zero one the degree exponent of the
graph will always be Alpha plus three
the purple stuff does not change the
degree exponent of the graph it will
change the degree distribution but if it
cannot change the degree exponent so I'm
sort of cheating here a little bit
because I'm saying the network can go up
to time n gamma uh so there is this m uh
so up to time n gamma the network you've
also according to something n times
point zero zero zero zero one and after
this the network does something else for
most of this segment of n
so I'm hiding the scaling of n but this
sort of uh this is what happens to the
system
so uh so just to sort of summarize what
we thought about you know so the initial
guess that oh you can maybe figure out
what the degree exponent is do log log
plots and try to understand changes in
the degree exponent these sorts of
estimators don't work
and so one can think about more general
questions if you have some general
function f that controls the Dynamics of
the time and Gamma and a different
function G that controls the Dynamics
um can you actually identify this you
have no idea what gamma is you have no
idea what f and g are can you identify
where the change point is
so a natural question would be what if
you actually changed the
coefficient in front of K
right I guess by rescaling I think that
might
just largely change it would might end
up something like this
so if it's like 2K plus Alpha once you
do the division this that thing comes
over here
so it end up in a similar sort of class
I see because you this preferential
attachment this divided by this
but but it is a good question I mean
what would happen if you have General
FNG but not precisely with the change
point right
when you have a change point this this
argument no longer works precisely sure
sure you have a different fnng so the
normalization will work a little
different sure yeah
uh what would
uh what would happen if gamma is
changing within gamma is going very good
question so I'll come to that sure yeah
yeah because I have a sexy name for it
so I would like to use that sexy name
the only big anyway so okay so uh so you
know these are the sorts of questions
this is called non-parametric change
Point detection because you don't have
any information about f and g and Gamma
and so on and so just to summarize in a
few slides uh what we managed to show
with cyan Banerjee and and Ian
Carmichael is for for a general under
General assumptions on your FNG
um you can kind of understand what
happens to the degree distribution of
the graph uh and sort of show
concentration in a pretty strong sense
and using this concentration of the
degree distribution of the graph you can
kind of uh come up with the following
change Point uh algorithm which I'm
trying to describe in words so you keep
monitoring the degree distribution of
the graph
um and what you do is you compare it
with the degree distribution of the
graph when it when the network is of
size n over A10 and you become alarmed
the first time where there seems to be a
big change in the degree distribution of
the graph so this is your reference
comparison and you keep comparing this
as a time as a Time series with the
degree distribution at this fixed time
and so it turns out that this is
consistent these sorts of uh estimators
are consistent but again there are tons
of open problems because if you actually
see how these things work in simulations
it's really bad so you know difference
between math and actual applications
um the rate of convergence for these
sorts of estimators are is super bad
okay and so so coming to sumit's
excellent question so you know one might
ask so now what if your change doesn't
happen at time M gamma but let's say
square root n so this is sort of the we
call it the Big Bang uh model so uh up
to Time 1 to square root n let's say or
in general n to the gamma the network
evolves according to something but from
time n to the gamma all the way to n so
Times Square Root n all the way up to n
the network does a different Evolution
mechanism
so we didn't think too closely about uh
sort of change Point detection but we
thought more about structural properties
so the first thing which seems sort of a
natural uh
should be obvious is what happens
between n to the gamma to n this is the
thing that should sort of Drive the
empirical degree distribution so if most
of the time from square root 10 all the
way up to n
for most of the time if you have some
function F1 which is driving the
Dynamics then this is what should
control like empirical degree
distributions it turned out to be super
hard to prove but this at the end this
obvious result is true that the the
second function controls
um the degree distribution of the graph
but the so where does uh you know how
can you find uh if there is a change
point in the system it turns out for
specific causes of these attachment
function Dynamics
um change does occur in sort of these
macroscopic functionals like the maximal
degree so maximal degree statistics but
this is all you know for specific
choices of models before and after uh
change point for specific uh classes of
these changes the maximal degree does
experience the change point but not sort
of bigger average functionals like the
degree distribution
okay so now let me come to sort of last
topic and then we're done so this is
sort of related to network co-evolution
and so I'm going to give you two
motivations mainly because
um I want to advertise this remarkable
result by melsted uh and chabulu in the
2000s
so um so first motivation for Network
Revolution is vertices you want models
where the network influences individuals
but what the individual does influences
Networks
the second motivation is the following
so preferential attachment type models
where vertices enter the new vertices
enter the systems and connect to
pre-existing vertices this somehow most
of the models assume either Global
Knowledge of the network you know all
the degrees in some sense or they assume
sort of uh the degree is the most
important factor
so both of these seem maybe not so
realistic either uh you know in many
cases people don't know the entire
structure of the network or in principle
even if you do believe something like
this sort of the attractiveness of
individuals should depend not just on
their friends but maybe the number of
friends that their friends have Etc so
let's say on LinkedIn you know it's not
just how many I'm attracted to someone
not just based on how many friends they
have but how many friends they have the
kinds of connections they have
so one specific such example is for
example page rank attachment so suppose
I'm trying to game the system I'm trying
to increase my own popularity
so what I can do is the following so
pagerank scores uh this is famous Google
algorithm so essentially uh many of you
know all this but uh pagerank score if
for a directed graph if you're given a
damping factor C between 0 to 1 it's
essentially the pagerank scores of the
vertices in the network is the
stationary distribution of the random
walk which has the following Dynamics so
using the directions on your graph the
probability C at each step it does the
usual uh random walk again using
Direction so from here I can only jump
here from here I can jump here or Etc
but with probably one minus c i can
randomly I can jump to a randomly
selected vertex in the entire network
and uh so um these page rank scores they
satisfy these linear systems of
equations uh not too important and uh
but the the main question one can ask is
if I'm a new individual in the network
maybe I want to increase my popularity
somehow and somehow I know the page rank
scores of individuals in the network so
I connect to someone with probability
proportional to their page Rank and this
page rank score is now a more Global
measure of people's uh popularity
um and so for example for directed trees
you can explicitly compute what the page
rank sports are and they turn out to be
so for a particular vertex you look at
number of individuals who can directly
connect to them numbering individuals
who are at level two and so on and you
get sort of a nice uh uh exact formula
in particular telling you that page rank
scores depend not just on the degree but
in some fashion in a weighted manner on
on the neighborhoods of of a Vertex so
punchline so now suppose I want to
change the Dynamics of my model where
new vertices come in and they want to
connect to someone with probability
proportional to their page rank uh is
this you know is this an interesting
math model can one get anything
interesting from these these things Etc
so this is the basic question and uh so
uh this weirdly respect or maybe not
weirdly for me was uh very surprising
this page rank type attachment uh model
is actually similar
to a completely different class of
models called the web surfing model
so here uh here maybe our motivation is
okay you know all this preferential
attachment individuals come in they
somehow need to know information about
the network before deciding where to
connect but the way that we uh find out
how uh Network individuals in the
network are interesting is we randomly
surf in the network we select an
individual at random a web page at
random look at where that web page
points to and then we go there Etc
so sort of we randomly explored the
network and then eventually you're like
ah you know I'm tired I'm tired of all
of this let me go and binge on Netflix
so at some point you stop
and uh so uh one can think about
um a co-evolutionary network model uh
with the following super simple Dynamics
again this is I'm not claiming this is
very realistic but the model is the
following so suppose you have
constructed your network at time n it's
a directed graph you start with the root
the director graph at time n plus one a
new vertex enters the system
and so it selects a Vertex uniformly at
random in the network because it doesn't
know where it would like it doesn't
exactly know the structure of the
network so selects a Vertex uniformly at
random and then what it does is it
selects an exploration the number of
exploration steps to the root variable
so how much time it's going to spend
sort of walking up the tree okay so
again this is uh very unrealistic the
random walk only uses the directions of
the the network
until it gets tired and then it goes and
uh binges on Netflix okay but once it
has explored the tree it stops there
connects to to the vertex where it
stopped and so the main thing that uh
controls all of this is this probability
Mass function which controls how long
this random walk uh sort of explores the
graph
and once a network once a Vertex has
done it it's now changed the structure
of the network
so just to give just to give you an
example so
um so let's say you start with vertex v0
and then V1 is connected to vertex v0 so
now let's look at the green vertex so C2
the choice of vertex V2 is I've decided
I'm going to start exploring the graph
at vertex V1 so that's V1 and then the
number of steps is I immediately get
bored I look at this web page and say Ah
that's an amazing web page I'm done so I
connect over here the next uh you have
uh C3 so vertex 3 it decides I'm going
to sample vertex V2 okay I've sampled
this and now I I have four steps I'm
going to go for four steps so in this
case I go one step two steps and I've
reached the root so I stop over there
okay so there's a condensation
phenomenon where in if you do end up at
the root you just stop there there's no
more you hit the frontiers of the
internet which of course is not exactly
feasible but uh that's what happens okay
so this is how the the network evolves
once you hit the route you stop but
bottom line you explore the graph for a
little bit and then you stop just thus
changing the structure of the network
and influencing uh next set of random
walks that come into the the system
and uh
in the previous the
there's no correspondence in the color
coding right no so this is a choices so
okay so at
four this is this is uh V4 has 4 has
decided to select vertex V2
a select this and then I'm going to go
for one unit of Step so I've selected
vertex V2 I go to vertex V1 and then I
get bored and I connect over here
yeah so these are the choices so C
denotes the choices that I make like
where do I start exploring the network
and this represents how many steps I
will go up in the network before I stop
let's say C4 again goes One Step uh
after V2 goes to V1 yep it stops there
that's it and and stops that's it that's
why you're done I'll written a line a
pink line from whatever cream line from
V4 to B yep right thank you yeah so this
is the basic uh model and uh so the main
thing I want to advertise is this
amazing result of chebolu and melsted I
think in 2008 where what they showed is
suppose your um exploration model
or the number of steps that you explore
the graph has a geometric distribution
with probability P so what this
basically means is once you have
explored your graph uh you want you
decide am I done today or do I want to
explore one more web page and the
probability of this is sort of
independent uh based on your previous
steps so if you do the geometric local
exploration
um then it turns out this model is
exactly the same as the page rank
attachment scheme so vertices connect
come in and connect to other vertices is
probably proportional to the current
page rank sports with this relationship
between the damping factor and the
probabilities
okay so these two at first are competing
questions I would like to explore the
graph and then connect somewhere or I
want to connect with probability
proportional to some Global attachment
function are actually sort of very
closely related sort of a beautiful
paper
okay and so what they found in the paper
and I'll tell you what we did and then
I'll stop so what they found is a sort
of face transition so if p is less than
or equal to half they found that the
expected degree of the root is of order
n
so there's condensation around the
whereas if p is greater than half then
the expected degree of the root scales
like some sublinear function of n
okay and so this is sort of expectations
Etc but this is what they found some
sort of phase transition and the main
question is can one develop general
theory to analyze these sorts of network
models
and so essentially what we showed is you
know as long as your expectation of your
um exploration step is finite these
Network models converge to in the local
weak convergence sense to limiting
random trees and none of the details are
too important but maybe let me just come
to the the punch line so
so lots of these things are controlled
by how many steps you want to explore
your network and so if you look at the
distribution of this you can associate a
random walk with this sort of uh with
this with this distribution
and these sorts of random Works uh under
some assumptions there has been a lot of
study on the quasi-stationary
distribution of these random blocks so
more precisely you can ask if I
condition the random walk to do
something weird then what properties
does this random walk have so for
example suppose my expectation Z is not
equal to one
that means uh this random walk either
has a propensity Rift upwards or drift
downwards and suppose I say I start at
vertex one and a condition that I want
to come back to Time come back to zero
not come back I would like I started
vertex one I would like to go to zero
eventually but after a super long time
so if you have a downward drift you
really want to get to zero so this is
sort of unlikely if you have an upward
drift then you know you're saying I
would like to eventually come back but
after a very long time again this is
unlikely and what uh daily in 1969 what
he showed is these have sort of
exponential type uh Behavior so this
scales like e to the minus n log R where
this R can be computed using information
about the probability generating
function of these random box
okay so what is the point of all of this
it turns out very weirdly uh that this
particular quantity this R controls many
of the properties of this random box so
two completely unrelated things
quasi-station distribution of random
walks on on the interval and this this
particular graph model are very closely
connected for example if you look at the
degrees of vertices not the root but
vertex one vertex two and so on they
scale like this n to the 1 over r
if you look at the uh in the case where
the expectation of Z is less than or
equal to one so you stop within time
less than or equal to one the degree
distribution of the graph convert this
to something and the exponent of that is
this minus r
if you and sort of the I guess the
maybe sort of expected result if
expectation Z is strictly greater than
one then there's condensation around the
root so lots of these vertices lots of
these walks end up at the root and so if
you look at the degree of the root this
divided by n converges to some sort of
non-trivial random variable
okay
um and so I'll just start with this sort
of there's no face transition in the
height so one might think okay there's
this condensation at the root so maybe
these uh these networks basically look
like the root with like a whole bunch of
things attached to it and then maybe
just a little bit after this and it
turns out this is not true the network
itself scales logarithmically in the
size of the the network it's just that
in some regimes a whole bunch of people
end up at the root okay so that's it I'm
going to skip all of this and uh and
stop over here so thanks for your
attention
foreign
our next speaker sets up we can have
time for a few questions
so this is a slightly different
direction uh
it's on okay so if you look at a fluid
as it freezes okay uh it will start in
some random place and start to grow a
little Crystal there and that'll grow uh
seed detection I don't think is all
there are a lot of the actual growth of
that is very badly understood so that
generally this is called nucleation
Theory and its predictions are way
orders of magnitude bad okay so we don't
actually know how that growing Crystal
which we can think of as the graph I
think we don't know how it's we don't
know the rule as to how it's growing
okay but I wonder
uh you that in your talk you seem to be
talking more about if I knew the uh rule
for the how it grows so can you ever go
the other way can you get information
about that growing graph and tell what
the rule was for how it's growing yeah
it's a good question so uh there's work
now by like a bunch of statisticians
like Van Der Waite who's been looking at
four Network models if you want to
somehow estimate the function that
determines how this network is growing
can you do it consistently can you
derive more fine scale properties so
what we've been thinking about is more
suppose you forget all information about
the vertex labels you don't know who
came first who came can you find out
where the network actually started from
and the main yeah the main motivation is
it's we expect the same things to work
for epidemic models so you have
epidemics starting from a graph let's
say or if there's any random graph and
you get to observe some information
about how the epidemic evolves on the
network work like how many who are
infected status of people
then can you find out who started
to take your one
in your intuition here you seem to think
that there will be a starting point and
that's it but as it's growing why isn't
there in creating new scenes
I mean it is I mean every vertex that
comes in it more people come in and
connect potentially connect to it yep
but every vertex has the potential to
connect new seats or start new seeds
Okay we have time for one quick question
but
so all your analyzes are for trees right
actually the last one with the
preferential attachment attachment
scheme the random Walker would you be
able to do that in a directed version of
the preference of attachment model where
m is larger than one no so or we haven't
uh been able to do it that's a very good
question I mean and you would expect
similar results to hold
uh it'll be hard yeah I mean no we do
expect similar results to hold that's an
easy thing about a proof are you
expecting the results of all no but a
slightly separate question uh same in
the same light uh you know there's a lot
of literature now on fake popularity
like you have new individuals coming in
and making a ton of Twitter followers
can this change the Dynamics of the
network so this is related to the seed
detection problem under which cases can
this change uh you know your ability to
find who infected the graph so yeah very
interesting questions most of our stuff
is for trees okay thanks okay it seems
my task to negotiate with the next
speaker about the delay give